All right.
Now let's see how TV support was
added to the Universal Media Player.
On the GitHub page,
you can see a complete dif of
the code changes that were made.
Of course, there's a link to
this in the instructor notes so
there's no need to memorize anything.
While you're going through this,
pay special attention to the manifest.
This dif is pretty good, but
a few changes were actually
committed before this dif was made.
So it's probably about 90-95% complete,
but it doesn't quite get everything.
Right now what I'd like to do is
walk through the essential pieces in
Android studio.
Here we are inside the manifest,
the first step is to update the manifest
to include leanback support,
being careful not to require it since
we're running multiple devices.
And because we intend
to run it on our TV,
we need to set the touchscreen
to not required.
Now let's create an activity to run
on the TV which we specify using
the leanback launcher category.
Here's our main activity for the TV.
As before, our plan is to use the
leanback's browse fragment as the main
UI, so the first step is
to create a layout for it.
Also as before, the layout does little
else but hold the browse fragment.
If we ran the project to this point
without including any other code we
would see an empty browse fragment.
Notice that right now we only
have a mobile configuration.
Launching that will cause
the phone UI to appear on the TV.
Let's see what happens.
Here's the UAMP mobile
UI on the TV emulator.
This is in fact proof that
Android TV is just Android.
Now you can still run
the TV UI by exiting UAMP and
launching it again from
the TV home screen.
And here's the empty browse fragment.
Or you can create a new
launch configuration for
the TV that specifies the right
activity to run from Android Studio.
And here's how you do that.
Under Configurations, select Edit.
Then add a new one, for
an Android Application.
Specify the module, and
choose the TV activity.
Oops, didn't give it a name.
Then hit OK.
Now when you run that
launch configuration,
the right UI will come up.
Now it's time to populate
the browse fragment, and
to do so, we'll use the media browser
you saw in the Android auto lesson.
Scrolling up a bit,
I want to point you to this comment.
The details of the media
browser aren't important,
beyond that it provides a tree structure
of media items you can explore.
A media item can be playable, like
a song, or browsable, like a playlist.
UAMP is hardcoded to expect the three
levels of media items that you see here.
The first level is
a category of categories,
like genre which will go
here on the header items.
The next category is music style,
like rock or jazz.
They'll go here on the rows fragment.
Finally, we have actual songs which
will be displayed on a separate UI.
First, let's create the header items.
We do so
inside the media browser callback.
This gives us a list of media items
which can be playable or browsable, and
they contain metadata about a song or
category.
At this first level, we'll create a
header item for each of the media items,
and the pattern is exactly the same
as you've seen in previous lessons.
Next if the item is browsable, we'll
explore the music hierarchy deeper and
create a row for its contents.
Here the browsable items are going to
be music styles, like rock and jazz.
You can see how the second
level is explored
inside the row subscription callback.
Also, as before, we'll need
the presenter to display these items.
Here presenter can take either
a media item or a queue item as input.
And if you scroll down a bit you can
see logic to set the description and
to fetch the album artwork.
At this point, if we run UAMP again,
let's see what we get.
Here you can see the header items and
the row items we can drill down
into further using a separate UI.
Back in the browse fragment,
we set up event listeners to respond
when one of our row items is selected.
These will open up a vertical grid
fragment and this is just another
leanback class that works a whole
lot like the browse fragment.
It just happens to layout its
content a bit differently.
Inside the vertical grid fragment you
can see we also use the media browser
subscription call backs
to populate the UI.
The principals are identical to
the material we've already covered and
here's how they look in action.
When one of the songs is selected
on the vertical grid fragment,
we'll want to start a playback activity.
Notice that we actually
kick off playback here
using the media controller.
Although, of course, we could do so
instead inside a playback
overlay fragment.
Now, let's have a look at
the playback overlay fragment,
another leanback class that
provides playback controls.
The media controller will
handle the actual playback.
All we have to do inside this class
is map the UI control actions
to commands for the media controller,
and we do so using this event listener.
Here you can see how we
forward an action on the UI to
the media controller.
And here's how that looks in action.
At this point you have everything you
need to know to build a great leanback
application.